that's what evolutionary biologists have
argued that if you give females the
choice and there's high inequality among
men say in wealth it would be fitness
maximizing for them to allocate
according to the available resources but
what it does do is that it'll inevitably
create a pool of low status unmarried
men if there's too much polygeny and
those are the guys who cause problems
because they're faced with possibly
being zeros in the evolutionary race and
so they are willing to take big risks in
order to catapult themselves up the
status hierarchy and have a chance to
get into the marriage and mating market
i had a conversation with a friend
daniel a couple of months ago on the
podcast and on it he explained to me
that a lot of the traits that we
associate with human behavior these sort
of
unwritten rules that govern the way that
we go about our our lives
he
summarized it as cultural conditioning
masquerading as human nature because the
only time that we've been able to do
uh psychological experiments which have
been sufficiently robust and well
practiced using the scientific method
has only been during this time this time
period what's your thoughts on that
cultural conditioning masquerading as
human nature
yeah well i think there's a lot a lot of
reasons to be concerned about that
because uh so much research i mean if
you look at the percentage of subjects
in psychology experiments that come from
modern western societies it's about 95
or 96
so my colleagues and i raised
concerns about this in a paper we
published in 2010 called the weirdest
people in the world where weird is an
acronym that stands for western educated
industrialized rich and democratic and
if you think about you know the origins
of human nature humans will evolve in
relatively small scale primate societies
uh hunting and gathering so that's very
much the kind of environment that a lot
of human nature has evolved for and then
you put him in a society with hospitals
lots of interaction with strangers
police forces judicial stuff and i mean
you can expect you're going to get a
very different phenotype when you do
that
what is the boundary
of
well so the important thing about the
acronym weird is that it's really a
consciousness-raising device and so what
i really do in the book is um
is try to get rid of the need to define
something like western and we try to
explain the cultural evolutionary
processes that lead down this particular
path and cause people in this society to
have
unusual psychology but one of the
exercises i do in the book is to explain
variation among european regions so i
can tell you why southern italy is
different from northern italy and try to
explain variation among different
italian provinces you know i try to
explain why eastern europe is different
than western europe and tag that to
events in european history that led to
the diffusion of some institutions
versus other kinds of institutions i'm
going to guess that there's a
particularly stark difference between
italy and china though
yeah so i mean you get these global
level differences but in one of my
chapters i look at variation within
china and try to show why more wheat or
more rice growing parts of china are
different from more wheat growing parts
of china again so again you can you can
tap the the variation within each of
these countries we can show the same
thing with india
dig into wheat versus rice
yeah so uh one of the key ideas that i
develop is that our psychology the way
we think about lots of things whether
we're individualistic whether we think
analytically versus holistically whether
we trust strangers or a more nepotistic
depends on our kin-based institutions so
our family structure
and
that can be affected by lots of things
and i think one of the important things
that mattered in europe was actually
religion had a big impact on this but in
china uh ecology and the kinds of things
you can plant affect this so in places
in china where you can grow patty rice
you need in fairly intensive large
groups to engage in sustained
cooperative labor and so this favors
more intensive clans so in china you can
show that certain ecological conditions
led to stronger clans and that leads to
more holistic thinking greater nepotism
and then you know some other downstream
effects of that so
human social psychology
responds to its local ecology in a way
yeah and and one of the one of the
things i i mean it can respond directly
to to environments but in this case it's
responding through the institutions that
are favored so you can imagine that
there could be other institutions that
aren't based on patrilineal clans which
is what emerged in china
that would lead to a different
psychology even though the ecology was
the same because there's there's more
than one way to to skin a cat so what
would be an example of that what would
be an alternative well so for example
the kinds of societies that existed in
california prior to the european
expansion
were you know hunter-gatherer societies
that had you know fairly intense kinship
but now los angeles doesn't have very
intense kinship and that's exactly the
same ecology just with different
different approach to it there must be
some fundamental features of human
nature i'm guessing there must be some
things that are like the building blocks
upon which institutions and culture and
rice and wheat can have their impact
yeah so i wrote a lot about that in my
book called the secret of our success
which came out in 2016. and one of the
key ideas so i was just mentioning these
kin-based institutions and family
structure but there's a reason why i
think that's the oldest and most
fundamental of human institutions and
it's because we do have instincts that
we share with other primates and other
animals so our tendency to be
particularly altruistic uh and giving to
members who individuals who were closely
related to genetically uh we also have
incest aversion towards you know
brothers and sisters but that can be
extended by incest taboos to shape our
social structure and shape our families
we have a pair bonding instinct which is
the foundation of lots of marriage
systems but of course there's lots of
ways to use that pair bonding instinct
some societies have poliginous marriage
some societies add some polyandry and
others have just normative monogamous
marriage are you familiar with the
westermark effect
sure that's just that's just incest
aversion essentially yeah would you be
able to explain how that sort of comes
about or how that manifests usually yeah
so the the idea is that you know like
other animals humans have to avoid
inbreeding so breeding with close
genetic relatives and the reason is is
that in all of us we contain recessive
alleles that can cause disease and if
you mate with a close sibling they're
likely to have the exact same recessive
and if you bring two recessives together
then that leads to the disease phenotype
so you have to avoid individuals who
share this common descent because
they're likely to have the same bad
recessives and one of the things that
evolution has done to allow us to do
that is when we're co-reared with
members of the opposite sex we develop a
disgust reaction to the idea of having
sex with uh with them and this is really
interesting and it kind of shows that
the texture of evolution because at the
same time we feel really close to those
people and we want to help them and
support them we're disgusted at the idea
of having sex with them
so you might have been having a warm
evening with your family playing
monopoly or something but then the never
that never breaks into having sex
because
there's good evolutionary reason for
that that's actually a way i get my
students thinking about this in human
nature when i teach that
the interesting thing from that it was
an example in
i want to say steve stewart williams
book where he says
a lot of the time if you have a family
that breaks up when the children are
young and the children don't get to
spend time together you get situations
where
brother and sister perhaps or um
daughter and father a lot of the time if
the father hasn't been a part of their
life come back together in later
adulthood and you have quite awkward
situations that can come out of that
because you haven't had this whatever
you want to call it westermark window uh
of imprinting
where uh the discussed mechanism has
been activated and then you loop back
around and
some pretty
yeah
so that's and that's one of the
interesting ways that uh
that scientists have been able to figure
this out is because there's things like
in taiwan and actually in china they
have minor marriages so you'll get um
babies essentially are betrothed and
they'll bring the the
future bride baby in and be careered
with her future husband and that's a big
mess in terms of marriage because it
activates the western mark effect even
though they're not technically genetic
relatives and so those
minor marriages they end up having fewer
children and they're more likely to
divorce all the things you might expect
yeah i wouldn't have imagined that that
would have stuck about given that it'll
have pretty poor outcomes you're
literally working against a pretty
ingrained
system and one reason why it might stick
around in these particular situations is
that you know china and india have a
long history of having male bias and so
they end up having a lot more boys than
girls and so if you want your son to
definitely have a wife in the future you
can lock in that wife if you get him
early six months old yeah
that's about as soon as you can so i
want to talk about monogamy and male
psychology you say that monogamous
marriage norms constrain the darker
aspects of male psychology talk me
through that
well i am
do i say darker i hope i don't say
darker um that was that's my uh okay
summary
so uh
yeah so the idea is is that um because
of the differences in male and female
biology human males can benefit from
multiple matings and there's nothing
about a pair bonding instinct so
gorillas have a pair bonding instinct
that prevents you from having multiple
pair bonds and this is true of men and
women except men can benefit uh because
they can you can think of uh serial
versus parallel so men can have babies
with multiple women at the same time
whereas women can only have one baby at
a time right and so there's few there's
less benefit for a woman having multiple
husbands than a man having multiple
wives and polygeny turns out to be
pretty common across human society so in
the largest anthropological database
that we have 85 percent of human
societies allow elite and high status
men to take additional wives
what was how was that study conducted
like who was the sample size
well so back in the 1950s
anthropologists began putting together a
database called the ethnographic atlas
um which contains over 1200 different
societies so it's it's you know in their
societies from all different continents
basically all the places where
anthropologists had collected data and
that was elite and high status males
were permitted to take more than one
partner yeah but even if you look at
hunter-gatherer society so 90 of
hunter-gatherer societies allow
uh prestigious men to take additional
wives and they don't typically take many
but they might have two or three you
know very rarely do you see more than
four wives in hunter-gatherers
why do you think that is just
difficulties for the male to support
more than four yeah yeah and so and and
the societies that do have monogamous
marriage uh it's typically because the
men are too similar right so there's no
benefit to oh if there's a hierarchy
yeah so if the men are more or less the
same because of the nature of the
economy then then then pollution doesn't
appear
is pillaging just uh
more efficient resource allocation then
well i mean
that's what that's what uh evolutionary
biologists have argued that if you give
females the choice and there's high
inequality among men say in wealth it
would be fitness maximizing for them to
allocate according to the available
resources so if you have a choice
between being the second wife of a guy
who's three times richer than your
number two choice
then that's an easy choice um i mean
there's things with paternal investment
and stuff because you know there's only
one male and you can only do so much
paternal investment but if resources are
the critical thing having enough food
say then then that logic makes sense but
what it does do is that it'll inevitably
create a pool of low status unmarried
men if there's too much polygeny uh and
those are the guys who cause problems
because they're faced with possibly
being zeros in the evolutionary race and
so they are willing to take big risks in
order to catapult themselves up the
status hierarchy and have a chance to
get into the marriage and mating market
are there any examples from history of
times where there's been
large swaths of
sexless men at the bottom of this
underclass
yeah it appears lots of times um
uh i mean the places that we know best
ethnographically are in these
geruntocracies that appear in africa
what's that and these are what's a
gerentocracy is ruled by the old
essentially and so and really it's old
men so what what some societies have
figured out is they put men through a
series of of initiation rights
and at various initiati you have to be
you know you say you might have to be in
your mid to late 30s to get through the
final initiation right which allows you
to finally take a wife so that means you
got this big pool of
20 30 something men who are basically
the warrior cast the warrior class and
eventually they're going to pass through
the right assuming they survive and get
to be old men and then get to be
poligionous but the older men are
basically taking the younger women so as
soon as they're old enough um
to have babies essentially they may get
married off as wives to these older men
and then there's all these young guys
roaming around and this this leads to a
lot of conflict because you need to
accumulate enough bride price
um and
you know
and so there's a lot of rating and
things like that but lots of societies
have had that so places where the elite
you know in the inca empire aztec empire
the elites all maintained large harems
and so um if you look at the early
descriptions from the friars for example
that that showed up in the aztec empire
they talked about how your average
indian uh you know average aztec man had
trouble finding a wife because the
elites had basically taken all the
available women yeah you talk about the
the math problem right yeah
yeah so this is this idea that when when
you know because males and you know
humans tend to have one male and one
female uh you can end up with this
huge you know huge pool of males when
the elite males take all the why all the
all the women as wives
it's not uh
it's not too far from what we're seeing
in the modern world though i'm aware
that it's not because polygeny is
happening all over the place in fact
even though marriage as an institution
and religious rights and stuff are
declining and you can say that
uh contraception and loser
rules and norms around pre-marital sex
and casual relationships and stuff like
that um there is a currently an
asymmetry i think the number of men
reporting no sex between the age of 18
and 30 tripled since 2010 so in the last
10 years that number's tripled you also
have women between the ages of 40 and 45
and the white women are the highest
users of antidepressants at the moment
and that is
sometimes pointed towards women who may
have hit the wall and are
looking at a future which is potentially
childless without a family because they
haven't been able to find a partner that
they feel
attracted to so you have kind of two big
swaths of
uh both genders that
aren't neither of them are particularly
happy with the situation both of them
are single
but you end up even though those women
haven't been tied up
by high status man at the top of the
tree you still get
the sexless underclass of men and
presumably whether it's because women
have been captured by another man or
women haven't hypergamously found
somebody that they're fundamentally
attracted to um
the sexist underclass of men are
probably not fantastic no matter why the
women aren't interested in them
yeah no it's the exact same logic except
here what's happened over the last half
century is that uh increasing female
choice and female labor participation
female labor market participation means
that it's now an option for women to not
get married and there's strong evidence
that women prefer males that are high
status higher status than they are
and so that means that women were
increasingly willing to just opt out of
the marriage market entirely
if they can't get a higher status man
which means you got this pool of men who
are who can't get a date basically and
apparently you can see this uh in
data from dating apps like there's a
relatively small group of men who get
all the interest from the women and
there's a whole bunch of men who never
get a single message
you said that getting married reduces a
man's odds of committing a crime
then when the man got divorced or their
wives passed away the likelihood of
committing a crime increased again after
that
yeah so what the data looks like it
looks like monogamous marriage now
pollution is a separate thing monogamous
marriage domesticates males and probably
even has a hormonal effect of reducing
testosterone reduce testosterone when
you get into get married and then again
when you have children when you have
children and that's in there's this
happens in lots of animals where you
basically if the male's going to invest
in the offspring you have to lower his
testosterone probably make a few other
adjustments so that he's willing to
protect the nest he's less disagreeable
he's less likely to get into risky
behavior and get into a fight with
someone and then be dead and then the
child doesn't have a father anymore
right right so he's not doing things to
kind of show off and impress the girls
he's doing things like a father would do
where and so what happens when they get
divorced is they have to go back on the
marriage and mating market so t levels
go up
and that means the risks of things like
crime things that would raise your
status you know you want to get some
more money so you can buy a fancy car or
whatever the relevant
uh currency is impressively you want to
yeah yeah whatever your status display
is and uh and yeah so that's that's the
consequence
rolling the clock forward seeing this
imbalance that we have in the sexual
marketplace at the moment and and it
doesn't really feel like either gender's
fantastically happy with it um i'm not
asking you to
come up with like an applied solution
but
what's your prediction if you were to
roll the the clock forward from here
with regards to this imbalance this sort
of gender imbalance that we have in the
sexual marketplace
yeah i mean that's a good question there
could be um a variety of technological
solutions so it could be the way for
example a lot of people find their mates
now on these dating apps it could be the
dating apps could be adjusted so there
would be more chance for
diverse matches
um and you know maybe that's going to
happen through competition amongst
different apps
uh another thing is we don't know what's
going to happen with sex robots
and other kinds of fantasy play based on
technology so that seemed i mean one
place to look is japan where there seems
to be a lot of use of that kind of thing
and there's whole there's a whole class
of males that have opted out of kind of
the dating environment what's the name
for those guys that live in apartments
together yeah well there's herbivores i
don't know if that's one you're thinking
of
no well it's a japanese word for it i
can't remember okay
there's like this
it's not ikigai but it's something like
that um but yeah they call them
don't the chinese call them like
herbivore men or or plant men or
something like that because the chinese
are going through this
we need to make chinese men manly thing
right now right uh they they don't want
them anybody to look like k-pop stars so
they've restricted the amount of time
that kids can play video games do you
see this
yeah so oh yeah yeah they're only
allowed to play video games between
eight and nine pm friday saturday sunday
uh they're trying to sort of
re-masculinize chinese men and they look
at the the k-pop stars and i i'm sure
it's called like
plant men or vegetable men or something
her before men might be it and um yeah
they don't want that
yeah it's um
it's a i don't know what it is i i would
like to hope that we could reinvigorate
marriage as an institution um i don't
know whether you saw today but the pope
got in trouble while the pope trended on
twitter for saying that people who get
pets instead of having children and
building a family are basically not
doing their uh
civic duty as a human uh a human being
okay which was a
i know i guess a
pretty outlandish thing for the pope to
say that
it's like enforced child rearing coming
from the pope someone did make a joke
around the fact that if there's anybody
that shouldn't be encouraging more
children to be around it's the roman
catholic church
they
haven't got a fantastic record yeah
they've got to work on their track
record but
yeah i don't know man sex robots thing
is an interesting one um
and it's got no easy i mean there are
some potential solutions but it doesn't
have an obvious one i mean you know
clearly gender equality is not something
we want to relinquish so whatever the
solution it's got to be involved gender
equality
and but that's going to lead to this
problem yeah it's
it's so strange to think back at the
fact that
there is absolutely no reason that women
shouldn't have equal access to
employment to education to the ability
to gain status and prestige and all of
those sorts of things
but bizarrely the fact that
women were held back over the last you
know
post-industrial revolution but pre-what
the last 40 years let's say something
like that 30 years um that made it
easier for women to find a relationship
with a man that they were fundamentally
attracted to because they weren't
competing themselves out of the overall
dominance hierarchy by rising up it it's
it's so weird that dynamics so
fascinating and
sort of
stark and brutal as well right right and
then the tricky part is if you're a
woman the higher you go up the status
hierarchy the the less attractive most
men get right
because you only like men that are you
know at least you're equal right really
like higher but but equals probably okay
lower that just seems lame well dude
think about how
brutal it is that you can spend a decade
building up your career or getting a phd
or doing a startup or whatever some
super high performing woman
and then you think right i
would also like to have a family let's
look at the potential dating pool that i
have there's like three guys there's
three guys out of seven billion people
that are above and across from where you
are
yeah no it's it's it's tough it's not so
let's go back to the the weird
characteristics and stuff the
stuff you had some something about
conformity was one of those
yeah so one of the package of of weird
traits is relatively low conformity so
conformity varies a lot around the world
and you can predict it with this kinship
data so when you have small monogamous
nuclear families you tend to have low
conformity now of course there's
probably lots of other things that
affect this but that's one of them and
then you can imagine that's going to
affect things like uh innovation
so in order to have you know robust
innovation creativity people have to be
allowed to go outside the rules and
think it's okay to go outside the rules
um individualism is associated with
greater innovation at least based on
patent and things like that
what is it
so
there's a homogeneity right
around this particular group of people
but within this we have different
subcultures you know silicon valley is
an example like that's this hotbed of
innovation and stuff like that
how do you see it do you see it as um
a predisposition for people that are
within this weird group the western
group uh or is there a glass ceiling how
do you see it
well no i mean it's at least so we've
studied the us patent data from uh
basically 1800 until about 1940 and we
can predict the amount of patenting in a
county by knowing the distribution of
last names because we can use the
distribution of last names to tell us
how clumpy people are in terms of
kinship
so no way
yeah yeah
and we can actually trace we we're using
newspapers to actually trace it to um
features of psychology so there's this
the psychologist michelle gelfin has
talked about norm tightness versus norm
looseness and if you're too tight with
the norms that's kind of like conformity
and so people aren't good innovators in
tight
societies what do you mean by tight
norms uh titan arms so
people who are from societies with tight
norms will report yes people are
watching my behavior i don't feel like i
can you know take my own actions i worry
a lot about how people judging me things
like that
i mean of course that you know that's a
feature of being human but it does vary
across societies and communities so
places that are relatively looser tend
to produce more patents you know cities
of course are tend to be looser because
you're not growing you know you're still
not living with basically the kids you
went to high school with which if you're
in a small town you know there's kind of
this permanent community right oh
obviously in any case we're getting to
the point where we can connect the dots
between
the you know the number of immigrants
flood into a place it gets looser more
innovation is generated and you can see
the psychological shift that goes along
with it at least based on the newspaper
data that's wild what does the newspaper
actually have to do with it
so what we can do is so there are new
techniques developed
you know basically in the field of
cultural evolution where we can try to
measure psychology by looking at the
text and so in the simplest versions of
this you just look at like collections
of words so people in tight societies
tend to use certain kinds of words
or you can look at individualism so
when you describe individuals do you
tend to describe them according to
traits and characteristics and
attributes or do you tell me who
someone's father is and what their
social group is and things like that
so one's more individualistic and one's
more collectivist so you can use these
to get psychological measures from text
and then you can apply those to
newspapers and books and you know
fictional corpora and things like that
so this is allowing us to look at change
in psychology through time and across
space
what is the least conforming
society that you found
well uh cross-nationally it's definitely
you know places like australia the us
places like that i mean the places you'd
expect australia being non-conforming
does not surprise me at all i've seen
some videos coming out of there recently
and they they they have scraps with each
other they don't need to go up against
the police
they they they have a problem with each
other what about loss of version that
was another one
well i have i mean there is some data on
cross national loss aversion although i
don't think we put that to the test yet
to try to see if we can explain the
variation but in the us you know
generally somewhere like california is
more individualistic and non-conforming
a lot a lot of trends in the us start in
california and then spread east so
something like silicon valley tends to
be more non-conformist and more
individualistic as well as places like
new york city you know urbanization is
correlates with this i would guess that
loss aversion having high loss aversion
would correlate with lower creativity
also because people are prepared to take
fewer risks right right interesting yeah
and something like overconfidence you
know it also tends to generate
innovation because really most
innovations you're probably going to
fail
for a variety of reasons so being
overconfident if a population is more
overconfident it tends to produce more
innovations because someone gets lucky
right so if everyone thinks they're they
can do it they all try and one of them
succeeds and then the society gets an
innovation that's cool what where where
are the most overconfident people
well americans are very overconfident
that doesn't surprise me
in the slightest
and so we're still mapping the variation
kind of within the us
yeah
i i've noticed this i went to austin i
spent five weeks in texas just before
christmas
and
it really is a stark difference between
i would say
confidence and sort of blue sky vision
to a degree as well and the way
interpersonally that people
deal with
the potential of success even for their
friends so as an example i got invited
on a really big show and i had
an hour and a half before i was going to
leave to get picked up i went on a
little walk and during the time that i
did this walk three of my friends from
america that i'd met within the last i'd
only been there two weeks three of my
buddies either texted me or rang me i
was like hey man just wait to let you
know i know that you're gonna be nervous
for tonight but i'm gonna be watching
you're gonna crush it uh really really
rooting for you
i'm thinking
have these have they coordinated between
they don't know each other but it was
just
so alien to me
as a
stuffy
tall poppy syndrome
stiff upper lip brit
ah okay um that was very that was very
it was lovely um but really stood out to
me
yeah well i don't know if it's related
to this but there is a um
another factor that i talk about in the
weirdest people in the world is
non-zero-sum thinking
so if you view the world of zero-sum if
you get more famous and more successful
that means there's less success for me
you're crowding me out but if it's a
non-zero sum world you can be super
successful and i can be super successful
because we're not we're not in
competition so the more you think of the
world as non-zero sum the less you're
bothered by the success of others in
worlds that are really um
zero-sum thinkers you get things like
witchcraft accusations jealousy people
sabotaging each other undercutting each
other all that kind of thing
do you get
is
is zero sumness associated with
population density
well i mean urban areas for example tend
to have a larger division of labor
uh more innovation going on more
economic dynamism so they actually are
less zero-sum whereas if you're you know
if you're in a small town with a finite
or shrinking population you know how
many dentists can you have so if if
if someone sets up a second dentist shop
you might actually lose customers right
but in a big city you know
do you think that islands
have any role to play here is there
something psychologically about being
water locked that impacts the way that
people and cultures grow
yeah i mean i i potentially but i
haven't i haven't really thought about
that so i don't know any any interesting
relationships with regard to islands
yeah i'm just thinking about the uk um
there is there is definitely a
i can't define them
perfectly but there's a zero sumness to
parts of uk culture um and i was
wondering whether that is because we
have such high population density you
know you have relative we have a lot of
people on quite a small bit of land
compared to america that has tons of
people on a ridiculously huge amount of
land
and
i wondered as well whether there's an
insulated mentality perhaps that comes
from being
surrounded by water
right well one place you can get a
zero-sum mentality cropping up is when
you're in say a city that is declining
say it was an industrial city and the
industrial age has passed so the
population's moving out there are no new
jobs then it actually is a zero i mean
it is a zero-sum world there's there's
not a growing pie there's a shrinking
pie ah so that's why
you get
a proliferation of people helping people
in cities that are on the up and it's
much more post-apocalyptic mad max
wasteland
correct as city is on i want all the
gasoline right precisely uh confirmation
bias what about that
um let's see
i don't think there's good data well i
mean there's some cultural variation in
confirmation bias but i don't know if
anybody's try to tackle it to see if
they can explain the variation in it all
right it was delayed gratification one
of them as well yeah yeah so there's
good data on that uh and that clearly
varies across societies and is
associated like so individuals who have
are more willing to defer gratification
are healthier they save more money they
get more education
um we know this can be culturally
transmitted we can transmit in the
laboratory um varies across societies by
a lot one of the arguments i make is
that um
protestantism seems to be associated
with greater deferral of gratification
so if you compare europeans catholics
and protestants you can show that they
tend to work harder and uh are more
willing to defer gratification so the
protestant work ethic is a genuine
cultural phenomenon yeah
there's a growing body of evidence to
say there's something to that now it
gets complex because a lot of people who
claim to be protestants are kind of
borderline atheists so
you know you we look for it more as a
kind of historical legacy so you look at
the protestant parts of germany saying
compared to the catholic parts of
germany so it's where does the
protestant work ethic finish and where
does uh garyvee hustle culture get up
and grind at 4 am begin that's the
difference that we have that's the
tricky part okay um what was that story
about parking tickets
yeah so one of the uh kinds of data so
we were trying to compare psychological
differences among countries to see if we
could explain them with some of this
kinstep structure and other stuff
and so there's lots of interesting
psychological data but we found this
data set from ted miguel and ray fishman
to economists and what they did is they
got data on parking tickets received by
diplomats who come to the united nations
in new york city from around the world
and what we were able to do so then each
diplomat or each diplomatic delegation
will accumulate some number of parking
tickets and they have diplomatic
immunity so this is a case where they
can park um and not have to pay or
receive any penalty the nypd still
issues the ticket so this creates a
database of people willing to you know
park in front of fire hydrants or block
driveways or double park or all those
kinds of things and so um if you tag the
the kinship intensity the kind of how
complex and intertwined families are of
the diplomats home country to the
diplomats you can explain a lot of the
variation and the willingness to to get
parking tickets so the canadian diplomat
got zero parking tickets no way diplomat
from sweden got zero
who got the most
um good question i don't remember
exactly um
i'm not sure why the fact that it's the
canadians that didn't get any is
kind of fits right
pretty funny um what about this
passenger's dilemma can we do this as an
experiment for everyone that's listening
sure so uh it's just a question so
you're you're riding in a car with your
friend and your friend is driving
recklessly and they hit a pedestrian
who's crossing the street and kill him
and uh so then
you know there's a legal case and you're
asked to testify
to lie in court essentially that that
your friend was driving under the speed
limit uh and and not recklessly and so
the question is do you want to support
your friend friend loyalty is a good
thing
uh or um or tell the truth in court and
then you're told by your lawyer that
your friend will get convicted then and
probably do jail time
it's one of those weird questions
because
both of the
outcomes are things that are supposed to
be valued
right you're supposed to loyalty to
friends everybody likes loyalty to
friends tell the truth in court sounds
like we should do that
but then the question is which one do
you pick right
what did you tease out to do with that
well there's quite a bit of variability
so um this will vary across populations
and you know this was all part of an
effort to see what we could explain
using this these measures of family
structure so we find that you know that
places with small monogamous nuclear
families people are much more likely to
say uh i would tell the truth in court
whereas places with big families where
people depend on relationships and you
get jobs through relationships and
you'll keep the same friends for your
whole life people say of course i'd be
loyal to my friend uh you know it's not
even a question
how significant it was i remember i i
asked this question in in a seminar once
and i i there was a it was mostly for
undergraduates but there was a postdoc
there who was working with me from
colombia and he was just
stunned that so many of the harvard
students would said they would uh tell
the truth in court because he was like
in colombia we would go with a friend no
way yeah
what
what was the
uh group of people that was the most
ruthless that you found
from the most the one that was just
prepared to throw their friend under the
bus
uh well i mean canadians were up there
uh
i think australians and americans were
up there brits too probably good good
keep it safe in court what about shame
and guilt what's the difference between
those two
yeah so anthropologists have long
noticed that uh there are shame-based
societies where shame is really the
governing emotion and that's the emotion
you feel when you violate a social
custom or a rule or uh
you do something to get you a bad
reputation and you're worried about how
other people perceive you
so in humans there seems to be a
stylized display so people feel like
they want to be small they want to
disappear from view and not be seen and
this contrasts with more guilt-based
societies where there's lots of
different
rules around and you might do something
like for example you might plan to go to
the gym on a particular day and instead
you eat a big pizza and take a nap so
you might feel guilt for that but really
your neighbor's not judging you it's
just you have set some standard for
yourself for which you're not achieving
this self-imposed standard so you feel
guilt and so a couple different ways to
measure this but it seems like there's a
lot of variability in the degree to
which society is guilt-oriented so the
dutch are very high on guilt and there's
hardly any shame uh whereas in lots of
societies in africa and the pacific and
stuff really shame is the main thing and
it's hard to find guilt you have to
search around to find find evidence of
guilt the same
action caused either guilt or shame
yeah so i mean you can these two things
can come together but like in
experiments you can pull them apart by
saying you know either people do
something and no one will never know or
you make something public
um you make something someone do
something that's a personal standard
versus a communal standard so in shame
societies there tend to be lots of norms
and so you have to spend a lot of time
in cognitive effort making sure you do
the right greeting and that you you know
you're behaving in just the right way so
there tend to be more rules and guild
societies there's fewer rules but people
have more of this self-aspirational
goals and stuff so they spend more time
thinking about what makes me special
rather than uh trying to you know see if
that should be imposed upon everybody
else i imagine that you must have big
clumps of traits that just bundle
together like this that most of these
are going to be correlated with each
other
yeah so a lot of the stuff i'm talking
about um at the cross national level so
across countries
this is dominated this is really a lot
of these things we've been discussing
are kind of one dimension now i don't
think they have to be one dimension i
think there's a partic particular set of
institutions and historical processes
which have brought all these together
because every now and then we find some
outlier society which is high on these
dimensions but not high on this one or
something like that so it's not that
there's some underlying dimension
sometimes when psychologists study this
they see psychological measures
correlate and they declare that this is
because it represents some underlying
thing in the brain that could be true
but it doesn't have to be true so
everyone on the planet has the same
biology pretty much
right
the um
i have to object to that we don't have
the same biology well so here's the
here's the thing though about biology so
a lot of times when people say biology
they they mean genetics that's why so
one of the one of the big points that i
make is that culture changes our biology
so we just talked about how marriage
systems affect our testosterone
testosterone is our biology so so if you
move from a monogamous to a collision of
society it changes your biology the
exact same genetic program you know in a
in a polygenic society when men get
married their testosterone doesn't go
down because they're still on the
marriage and mating market no way
so so the marriage system affects the
technology when you learn to read which
is a relatively recent skill it thickens
the corpus callosa in your brain and
gets gives you specialized circuitry for
recognizing letters in your brain so it
changes your brain biologically just not
genetically
wow so not only is our psychology
responding to our local ecology and the
society and the culture and stuff like
that but it's a two-way street between
what we were around how that impacts our
own biology our physiology and then that
subsequently predisposes us to
more types of actions which then bleed
back into culture and society and this
feedback loop continues right
[ __ ] that's interesting so i mean so
cultural institutions these kinds of
things across societies technologies
something like just having a phone in
your pocket maybe actually hurting our
memories so uh all of these things
affect our biology it's just that they
don't affect our genetics
what were the biggest
um
impositions but the biggest impact
on
um the people's personality was it the
rates of religiosity was it
the
family structure was it kinship was it
did you find out what the the main
impacts were
well it's hard to figure out what the
relative weight of these things is so in
the case of religion i have a whole body
of research showing that when people
belie believe in powerful moralizing
gods they're more likely to uh you know
be pro-social or cooperate with
strangers even when nobody's watching
them by themselves so you know because
the god is omniscient that seems to have
some effect on people's pro-sociality
but some religions say you know you
can't marry polignously and you can't
marry your cousins and so those are
changing the family structure so the
religion is having an indef indirect
effect on people's psychology through
that and then in the weirdest people in
the world they make the case that these
two factors lead to rising urbanization
in europe beginning in about the 10th
century and you know in the 12th century
or europe passes china in terms of
urbanization and having cities with a
complex division of labor with lots of
different jobs that people can do seems
to actually have changed the structure
of personalities so you know
psychologists have long told us that
there's a five five factors in
personality so things like neuroticism
and conscientiousness uh extroversion
and
um but it turns out when you go to
small-scale societies like amazonian
populations in bolivia
uh you just find two factors
so there's a good case to be two
actually
uh well none of the two in the original
five there's like an industrious
industriousness and pro-sociality
seem to be the two important dimensions
wow so that's something which is seen by
a lot of psychologists as the
fundamental um parameters that you're
playing with for someone's personality
and yeah you can go to a place where not
only do you not have any of them but you
also have two more
you have two different ones yeah so and
that's a case where a psychologist did a
completely inductive thing right they
just started giving people
questionnaires
and uh and then they got this result and
they could do it amongst lots of
different undergraduates so it seemed
like it was pretty robust but as soon as
you take it to a society very different
from a weird society
just like this is the conversation that
we started off with you get a completely
different answer which means the nature
of personality i think is an adaptation
to all the different socio-ecology and
occupations so you can imagine if you
have some genetic proclivity to want to
be by yourself
um if you live in a society where you
don't have a choice to become a
librarian or a computer programmer then
you're sort of forced to cultivate some
degree of public speaking or some degree
of social interaction because you need
to engage in trade or you need to get a
cooperative work group for your farm or
something like that but if you can get a
job as a librarian and just sit and you
know shuffle the books around um then
then you can just you become even more
introverted and you go down a particular
trail presumably as well
that will have a selection effect for
the people that are likely to be
successful in that society so the ones
that are higher status that have more
resources that have a stronger group
around them if you're the super
introvert in the society that requires
you to be extroverted and you are um
your predisposition is so so tight that
you're not able to step into that um
you're going to be competed out of the
gene pool so you end up presumably with
societies which over time
what do they begin to look more like
themselves how does that work yeah i
mean i haven't seen any research at the
genetic level but i do have a graduate
student who's working on this idea that
one of the things that modern societies
where you have lots of labor market
choice and mobility is it better
harnesses the available genetic
resources so imagine people varying like
how good how suited they are for
computer programming or how suited they
are for being a physician
or for being an economist or whatever
the various things are and what you want
to do is effectively shuffle the genes
that are best for those different things
into the right categories as opposed to
a cast approach where you know you're
born into the sandal maker cast and
you're going to make sandals it doesn't
matter what you like right
yeah um you said that an alien visiting
earth in
around about a thousand ad would
struggle to predict that the west would
end up being so dominant why do you
think that is
well because if you look at the world
around a thousand ce you know the the
most sophisticated urbanized societies
are in china and the middle east
um you know it's kind of the islamic
world with a real center in
persia in central asia um is producing
science and experimental method is
developed and the what becomes algebra
is developed and all these things
eventually the numbers is the symbol for
zero all these eventually move into
europe but at that point you know europe
looks like a backwater and so i have a
quotation from a scholar in toledo an
islamic scholar who talks about the
black barbarians to the south and the
white barbarians to the north and then
he goes through and he lists all the
contributors to civilization the
persians and the egyptians and um
the the folks in the fertile crescent uh
and
and the you know the europeans are are
classed with french and the danish they
don't they're the white barbarians in
the north wow
so what
happened what how is it that europe ends
up being so dominant if we were these
backwards hairy barbarian people only
a thousand years ago what is it that we
do that makes us so special
well the the case that i make for why
you know from 1500 to the current times
uh european institutions and european
populations spread around the world
i lay out a a
narrative that takes about a thousand
years to unfold but it begins with a
particular brand of christianity that
brand of western christianity that
eventually evolves into the roman
catholic church and one of the unique
things that that church did was it
adopted this peculiar set of taboos and
prohibitions around marriage and the
family and i make the case that this
transformed european families from the
kind of kindreds and polygenous
clans and stuff that we find
anthropologists have documented around
the world including in places like china
and in the islamic world into small
monogamous nuclear families
and this was you know the church didn't
intend to do this but this opened the
door for things like charter towns which
had constitutions where he had voluntary
groups of strangers getting together out
of mutual need because all they had were
these little monogamous nuclear families
so if you need a production group or you
need a group for security or social
insurance he had to form these groups
and sometimes they were monasteries
sometimes they were charter towns
universities actually started as labor
unions either for students or for
professors and so universities began
spreading all these different voluntary
institutions and that eventually over
centuries gives rise to our notions of
individual rights and democratic
government and stuff which form the
institutions which have now spread all
over the world so does a
more
atomized monogamous society is that
better for specialization within a
workforce
well it allows you to move so typically
clans would specialize and clans often
will maintain whatever knowledge they've
had and only pass it on to other clan
members but if you have the occupational
system that developed in europe you
could as a stranger just sign on to be
an apprentice of a master blacksmith and
you would learn his things and learn
from him and then you would have to be a
journeyman so now you're an official
blacksmith but you have to go do
essentially what's a postdoc so you go
to find another blacksmith in another
town you got to do some years with him
and you know then you're learning from
all the other journeymen who show up
there plus you're saying well how does
what he do compared to my previous
master and you're recombining different
ideas where if you pass things down in
family lineages the only recombining is
theft basically you know families are
trying to sneak and you know peek and
see what others are doing
i also guess that if you have a
big group and you decide that you want
to go off and live your life as a
superstar blacksmith the ability to pick
up your family and move them with you
when the family isn't
four people it's
20 people right it's a multi a pan
generational commune somewhere uh that's
basically
something grandma's not coming with you
so that you can fulfill your blacksmith
dreams and the problems are really
non-intuitive for uh for someone from
with from a society with monogamous
nuclear family because these societies
with intensive kinship you have lots of
really important responsibilities to all
kinds of relatives so you know you're
responsible for burying your uncle you
have to do uh rituals to the ancestors
to make sure that the land they'll keep
the land continuing to be fertile you
know if one of your cousins gets injured
you may have to avenge their their
deaths or their injuries or something to
make sure blood money is paid or things
like that so when you leave you're
you're in a cog in the wheel and you're
kind of leaving everybody in the lurch
without this all these important jobs
that you have so you're giving up on
lots of obligations but you're also
leaving your social safety net so as
long as you hang around these people if
you get injured they'll take care of you
and get old they'll take care of you um
but you know and to go to a town and not
have any of that is is a tough choice
did you have a look at jews or ashkenazi
jews and stuff i know they've got some
gene pool um oddities
in there
well they're a fun case because jews in
general are a fun case because you know
i open the weirdest people in the world
with looking at literacy and i make the
case that what we think of now is the
the standards that everybody becomes
literate and the fact that literacy is
you know schooling to make make sure
everyone's literate really begins to
spread with protestantism and it's
because protestants believe that
everyone should learn to read the bible
for themselves girls and boys this is
why there's led to lots of literacy in
girls because they had to read the bible
and uh but the exception to that is is
actually i only mentioned in a footnote
in the book but um after the destruction
of the second temple in the first
century a.d uh ce um jews decide that
all jewish boys should learn to read the
torah in hebrew and so
so jews become the you know the earliest
society with widespread literacy so
almost 100 of jewish males could read
the torah and then this opens the door
for jews to spread into urban
occupations all over the islamic world
and that's how the jews end up as a not
as a bunch of farmers which they were in
jesus's time but as this these urban
populations that become accountants and
all these other kinds of things you roll
the clock forward a couple of thousand
years and you have the highest number of
nobel prize winners per member of the
population by
it's some like ridiculous factor right
yeah
yeah and so i mean so i'm drawing on
this book called the chosen few but the
argument there is that once you have a
culture of literacy you get a culture of
debate about what the torah says and a
culture of commentary on that and that
just cultivates a way of thinking that
you get just from sitting at the dinner
table as well as you know other kinds of
training that you know if you're from
the kind of irish catholic background
that i'm from you know we didn't argue
about religion or politics or debate uh
scripture or anything like that
looking at the um previous setups for
family with regards to this more commune
pan-generational uh
living on-site with the rest of your
family and also what we spoke about
earlier on which is this difficulty we
have this atomization this
individualization of society i don't
think that
many people are superbly happy with that
at least existentially or psychology in
terms of the psychological health we
have rising rates of suicide amongst men
and
people report loneliness etc etc do you
ever see a time where we could return
back to
kinship or pan generational commune
houses where you and auntie and grandma
and daughters and cousins all live
together
yeah i mean uh this is definitely a
problem right because the the trajectory
of society is increasingly bringing us
down not only to monogamous nuclear
families but now with things like social
safety nets uh and unemployment
insurance really we can operate as
individuals right we don't even need to
get married anymore
and uh
so and that leads to loneliness
dislocation people don't live near their
families as they pursue careers and
these kinds of things um and that leads
to lots of mental health problems and
what not ever not everyone's well suited
in that so
i mean you might think that the
trajectory of society has got to figure
out a way for people to live in
community again now might not be by
building patrilineal clans uh but it
might there might be lots of ways in
which humans can live in enduring
communities and get the kind of warmth
of having this group that you know is
there to take care of you and being
surrounded by um a kind of fellowship uh
that that so i i do field work in the
south pacific and you know one of the
ways i describe the feeling of being in
that village where you're related to
everybody is you know just being wrapped
in a warm hug and i think that's what a
lot of people crave um the tricky part
is to to continue to energize economic
growth while still getting the warm hug
yeah it's strange right because the
existential void is filled by
achievement and accolade and status and
prestige and the byproduct of that is
you're probably a pretty good commercial
engine pretty good economic individual
um whereas
if all you need is
a bottle of beer on the porch with
your grandmother sat next to you and
your daughter sat on your knee you're no
longer driving as hard
yeah that's the tricky part
i don't know i i'd be very very
interested to see what happens with that
commune style
multi-generational living i think i'm i
don't know i think it'd be pretty cool
but i don't know whether it would just
get
i don't know whether you can go back to
that and i've just thought as well is
this a
a potential malignant side effect of ubi
that no one's really talking about that
if you increase that social safety net
for people at the bottom
you
encourage individualization and
atomization of people in society is that
is that a
side effect of it yeah so uh things like
those kind of social safety nets at the
individual level is not going to help
this problem
because at least now lots of people do
rely on kin and that does forge kin
links they form long-term enduring
friendships where people help
others out but if the government's
always going to step in and lay a floor
down for everybody then you're not going
to have to build those enduring human
relationships it's actually also a worry
with
technology this is a related worry so it
used to be that as a kind of merchant or
something you would have to cultivate
a reputation for honesty and one the
best way to cultivate a reputation for
honesty is to be honest right to
actually be honest and be trustworthy
and you know when you sign a contract or
when you make a handshake agreement that
you're as good as your word uh but now
everything is secured by these
electronic transactions like you know
the uber's got my credit card number so
it doesn't really matter if i'm trusting
you know they already got me so it means
that i don't necessarily i'm not
cultivating this sense of that i am a
trustworthy guy because everything's
fixed by technology oh
so they make us less trustworthy yeah so
the trustworthiness has been
externalized it's been outsourced and
buttressed by technology i think i read
about how um
there is a concern
among linguists and child developmental
psychologists that the use of smart
speakers
is going to
cause um reduced uh speech skills among
young children because they won't you
don't ever say um
hey siri please turn on the bedroom
light you don't say the please
there's never a thank you there's never
a please a lot of the normal social
graces that you go through they're just
not there
did i just set your phone off when i
hated it you'd get in people said hey
siri and siri responded
i did say please um but yeah i mean
that's another thing right you you
associate you use
technology to encourage you it's so
funny thinking about the fact that you
said
because
there is a a
safety net but it's not so high that you
could live without the assistance of
your family uh people are almost forced
together by necessity
um and i don't know there's something
about
this desire for sovereignty that we have
at the moment right in the modern world
to be a sovereign individual who has
agency and control over their own
trajectory and so on it kind of works
against it you want to say well no i
want to choose to be with my family i
don't want to have to be with my family
you go well
you say that but you don't know what's
best for you a lot of the time it may be
that having to have your family
is actually better for you than choosing
to not have them and then
the existential loneliness that you
don't know how to fix it was fixed it
was fixed when you needed them
right exactly and i think there's a so
one of the things we study in my lab is
the idea that our minds are cue to the
group for which we're socially and
economically interdependent with and
that we have special bonds with people
that we're economically interdependent
with and the more you have these
programs the
it just reduces any economic
interdependence at all and you end up as
an island right but you know at least
the nuclear family there used to be one
job for for the female and one job for
the male and they were dependent on each
other my dad can't make toast right um
so he's dependent on somebody to make
his toast for him was kind of the idea
but now you know we don't have that
anymore you said that belief in an
afterlife that depends on one's behavior
in life is associated with greater
economic productivity and less crime for
every 20 increase
in those who believe in hell in heaven a
country's economy will grow an extra 10
percent
yeah
that's wild that's research from one of
my colleagues in the harvard economics
department just analyzing uh data that's
through time on gross domestic product
and uh data on religious belief and how
that changes and it you know it's
interestingly it's not heaven it's the
hell it's that's the kind of bad side
and the more people believe that there's
a hell out there
they behave a bit better and that that
leads to some economic prosperity hell
is what every manager of a sales team
needs to be threatening their staff with
that's the right motivator don't get
tony robbins in don't do
neuro-linguistic programming just bring
some theology back in and you're
laughing
uh joe we made it
thank you very much for today what are
you working on next what have you got
any other cool cool stuff that you're
doing in your lab
the big stuff we're doing is the stuff i
alluded to with the textual data so
trying to extract uh psychology from
texts and the kind of big game in the
lab right now is the latin corpora so if
we can extract this stuff from latin
then we can go back a thousand years and
we can track it change this is like
being uh like linguistic lexical
archaeologists
yeah so i get a team of like uh you know
digital humanities guys latin scholars
historians
economists that's pretty cool
it's good fun where should people go
they want to keep up to date with the
work that you do well well so my pretty
pretty good website for both myself and
my lab and if you just google my name it
should come up it's like thanks joe okay
see you chris what's happening people
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace